have a look at the first one now I've
deliberately chosen one where if you
have a look again if you just mentally
do your discriminant right based but
it's 4 minus 4 AC we minus 20 so you're
getting a negative distribute here okay
so the whole point is that you can't
actually with these roots they don't
exist in the real number system okay so
I can't find them and then add them or
find them and then multiply them right
you can't actually try to cheat the
rules and do that but it's much more
efficient just to use these methods okay
so to begin with for this example let's
just simply say what's the sum of roots
in this case alpha plus beta is by this
be on a which is minus 2 on one so it's
just negative yeah happy with that the
sum of the roots I'm going to stop
calling in the product of the roots even
though that's why it is more generally
speaking it's the subway routes to it
time is C on a right 5 over 1
it's just fine okay you're happy with
that so this alpha beta there's alpha
beta now to get to this next one okay
there are two categories of these and
I've got both of them on the board
the first thing is like why I don't know
what happens to is because I don't know
what alpha is right but if I deal with
this guy as a whole it's not like
solving a Sudoku right if you just focus
on one particular square you like I
don't know but if you look at the
squares around it it gives you a clue
right so I'm gonna take it as a whole
I'm just getting expanded me right if I
expand I get this do you agree with that
like that's just taking the terms
through the binodals right so once I've
got that though I can see that this guy
is composed of these two right in some
combination on this the sum to a time is
double there's someone in China there's
just a for hanging out in because
because why not okay
so therefore every one of these kinds of
questions here so you have like a pi/3
here / 4 & 5 here right they always use
these guys is the building blocks that's
all you've got to work with right but
that's all you need
you can buy them in an incredible amount
of ways right so if you have a look at
this I know what alpha being is it's
fine I know what alpha plus beta is it's
negative 2
and then I've just got a form hanging
out on the end so that looks to me like
x equals y ok thanks it's not too
complicated is it ok now you can see the
way I combined these when I let go to
cubics because there are more pieces it
does get a little bit more difficult but
if you logic it up it's still just as
it's just as easy to work with
so let's firstly just read off the
initial results right so the some one at
a time is have a look it's nice to be on
a which is minus negative 1 or 2 which
is 1 or 2 so it's a high the some tuna
time is C or hey which is just 2 that's
nice and then below this one the sum 3
the time alpha beta gamma is minus minus
3 - yep - bo name see on a - do ok great
now when you have a look at these guys
ok this one is not too hard but I take
the same approach that I do here right
if I put them all together consider them
as a whole I will see these building
blocks emerge ok so you have a look at
this and you say what about three
fractions a natural thing to do is I'm
going to get it I'm going to multiply to
get a common denominator so then I can
just add up the other yeah so for
example the common denominator here
being that I have an alpha head of beta
and the gamma the competent of it
clearly has to be alpha beta gamma right
so it's gonna be alpha beta or alpha
beta gamma plus on alpha beta plus on
Alpha Gamma yeah what do I have to
multiply each of those fractions by to
get a denominator of alpha beta gamma
look at the first one I've got x be
together because I've just got one there
right and I've multiplied by the
denominator in the same way I'm gonna
have to multiply this wood by alpha
gamma and the last one by alpha beta
that you don't need to go much further
to see when you add these all together
you have the sum to a time as the
numerator right do you see that and as a
denominator you have this guy that minus
3 or 2 yep
so just tidying up just TTB it looks
like that's - form 3 to me are you happy
with that
ok now just this last one is ever so
slightly different but the approach will
be much too soon ok what you have a look
at this the weight is different to this
question and this question is the one
that I just circled in red they have an
obvious way that you just do the next
step right it's like oh I expand that's
obvious
well I just added that's ok right but
here that's as simple as it gets
like what are you supposed to do with
that so you kind of have to
reverse-engineer it a little bit right
you have to think about where crabs
started from that could possibly lead
here ok now let me give you suggestion
if I start from either of these guys
right do you see that for either of
these that alphas betas and gammas are
already intertwined right they already
sort of linked together ok so if I were
to square either of these I would get
alpha squared B squared + B squared
gamma squared + or an alpha beta and
alpha squared beta squared JavaScript
they're all mixed up right so whichever
way you combine them in order to square
they'll all be kind of connected and
tangled up and that's not very helpful
so therefore I look at this guy this is
the only one which has the 3 separated
out the way they are here I'm gonna take
this guy and I'll square him have to
square somewhere right so I'm going to
do it is already tried okay I'm gonna
take alpha plus beta plus gamma because
I know what that value is right and I'm
just going to squared a lot okay with
that so that's alpha plus beta plus
gamma times
alpha plus beta plus gamma so when I do
that I get alpha square plus alpha beta
plus alpha gamma you see that that's the
first expansion put in brackets I'll do
the second one which will give me alpha
beta plus beta square plus beta gamma
you see I multiply everything by beta
and then my last one which will be alpha
tell me gamma plus beta gamma plus gamma
squared excellent so I've done the
brackets there just so I don't get
overwhelmed by how many terms I've got
so I can see there's a package three
threes right and then you can see I've
got the Alpha squared meter squared
gamma squared that I wanted and separate
there's just extra stuff flying around
all right
so let's separate out the stuff that I
want namely these guys right and what
extra stuff is there good is the two
alpha betas here him there's gonna be
two alpha cameras here and here and I
need to continue the pattern right in
fact you always get this kind of
symmetry so top a lot and so you can see
I've got two times the sum of the roots
two at a time
does that make sense it's not gonna go
to lots all okay so now be that I
started with this big all squared and
what I really want is that guy right you
see that I just bring this guy over the
other side and then I have him bind
himself you see that so therefore alpha
squared plus beta square plus gamma
squared e is alpha Crucis meters gather
full square or on half or squid so
that's going to be a quad up plus double
the Sun two at a time I'm sorry - of
course I'm take it over the other side
so two times two which is four
yeah is that what I got yep okay so
that's minus three and three quarters
tada
okay so you see how I kind of do
in Reverse right because I didn't have
an obvious super vacation step from heel
okay but I ended up with the same kind
of like I'm just trying to work out what
the booty blocks are and then once
you're doing but there you just evaluate